from the french ladies footballers meet
english lady footballers at uh football
somebody's bound to get a kick out of it
these were the trailblazers
the english forward seemed to be awfully
forward
england taking on france in 1937
determined to play on in spite of an fa
ban on women competing in their grounds
that's one of the 12 goals for england
that ban had come into force in 1921 and
would remain for 50 years
the ban was absolutely devastating for
women's football at the time gail
newsham has documented the story of the
dick kerr ladies club formed while the
men's game was suspended during the
first world war their matches drew
thousands of fans until the ban
gale played for preston rangers when
many still disapproved of the women's
game generations of people have been
brought up to believe that football's
not a game for for women
and and that goes back to 1921 to the
ban when they said that football is not
suitable for females it's quite simply
not true the lionesses victory uh
it proves that you know that they can
play football they can play it rather
well actually
with the spotlight firmly on their sport
today's players want to build on the
momentum here at preston north end the
women's first team still pay to play the
gap between the women's game and the
men's game is still vast after the
success of the lionesses some are now
asking can women's football ever begin
to rival the multi-billion pound
industry that the men's game has become
we need to start getting the coverage
just like the men's do every weekend the
men are on the telly and so the women's
game needs the same the more that people
can watch it the more the people will
england's women have done all they can
we would have been inspired by so much
growing up but now hopefully there's a
generation of people that will be
inspired by us
the fa now seeking to right the wrongs
of the past we work really hard to
create a strong legacy program so that
every girl in the country has an
opportunity to play in a local club
local school and we've still got more
work to do
at this summer school in salford there
are now more girls than boys
the name of the club a throwback to the
past the faces here very much the future
eight-year-old mia has already been for
trials for manchester united the success
of the lionesses confirming for her that
anything is possible it was really
amazing because last
year
the men they
they went into the finals but they
didn't win it
but this year the
girls won it and they took it all on for
us
for her and girls everywhere the goal
now to keep moving forwards becky
johnson sky news preston